what is going on everybody and welcome
to a reinforcement learning with stable
bass lines 3 tutorial series so stable
bass lines 3 is to reinforcement
learning like scikit learn is to general
machine learning the idea here is to
abstract away some of the more complex
and nuances of writing and applying
these reinforcement learning algorithms
and sort of homologize the entire
experience such that once you've created
your environment and you can you can
essentially just try all these various
algorithms really quickly really easily
and just kind of get a lot of the code
written for you that you're going to
have to write every single time and so
at least for me
when i was embarking on a recent series
for the simulating robots and doing
reinforcement learning to try to teach
the robot how to walk i did indeed find
this very challenging to apply
these existing reinforcement learning
algorithms to some environment and then
if you want to change it or anything
like that it becomes just a massive uh
massive headache so
anyways i eventually stumbled into
stable bass lines and found it to be
unbelievably easy to use so i highly
recommend it so with that to use stable
baselines three you're going to need pi
torch that is the back end that they use
so you can come here and install pi
torches by torch.org and you can get
started and then also you will need
stable baselines three which is just a
pip install stable dash baselines three
and then the extra stuff i don't
actually know if you will need the extra
i don't know what's included but grab it
anyways
so uh once you have that
let's go ahead and get started so we
will be using open ai gym as well i
believe gym is included when you install
it but i don't actually like see
anything specific here but you also
might need to do a pip install gym
and then also possibly some of the
extras but i think we're just going to
be using the 2d environment so pip
install gym
might be successful but if not uh check
the description so i'll throw something
in there there's also a tech space write
up so
if we have any problems i think it'll be
fine i think the only thing you'll need
here i'll copy and paste this in here
you'll need the box 2d so pip3 install
gym box 2d that's all we're going to use
from the gym
and obviously eventually we'll use a
custom environment i'll show you guys
exactly how to do that
as well but for now to keep things
simple we're going to use the open ai
gym environments
so
before we get too deep into that i could
spend a whole bunch of time on
all the theoreticals of reinforcement
learning i'm not going to do that i
think the best way to learn
reinforcement learning is to jump in and
if you find an algorithm that works
really well
then you can dive in and learn more
about that algorithm but i think you're
going to learn by using much better so
so i won't get too deep into the weeds
but what i will say is we are going to
cover some terms that you must know
before you get into this so first of all
we have the environment this should be
fairly obvious but it's what you're
trying to solve so carpool lunar lander
some other custom environment if you're
trying to make some ai play a video game
the game is the environment then you're
going to have models so this is just
what basically what algorithm are you
using it's your specific trained
algorithm is your model then you have
agent this is the thing that's
interacting with the environment so and
using that algorithm or model to do so
then you'll have observations or states
what's the state of the environment this
could be like imagery or visuals or it
could be other vector information like
sensors and stuff like that
you have an action these are basically
what is your agent going to do in that
environment essentially per step and
that's another term is just simply the
step so when you step an environment you
quite literally just take a step in
general you pass your action to some
step method the environment performs
that step and returns a new observation
and reward for you to continue in this
kind of loop until you're done so if you
think in terms of like frames per second
if you're playing a game at 30 frames
per second then you have 30 steps that
you would take per second it can get far
more complicated than this a step is
just simply progressing in the
environment and then finally when it
comes to action spaces you have discrete
or continuous actions you can think of
discrete like classifications cartpole
for example has a discrete action space
you go left or you go right it's nothing
in between there's no
there's no like continuous values here
it's left or right not somewhat left
somewhat right and so on discrete then
you have continuous you can think of
continuous like regression it's a range
of nearly infinite possibilities the
bipedal walker environment is a
continuous action space as is much of
robotics because you're going to set the
servo torque anywhere in a range between
let's say in the example of bipedal
walker negative one and positive one or
a servo position it's not always going
to be torque typically a continuous
environment is harder to learn but
sometimes this is a requirement so again
in robotics
this tends to be more of a continuous
type problem even though servos are
actually discrete with something like 32
000 you know positions
that's far too many discrete positions
to pass into your neural network so
instead we treat this as a continuous
problem but those can be converted into
often a continuous problem anyways can
be converted
in various ways to a discrete problem
and more on that later and and why we
might want to do that more on that later
too
so assuming you all have jim and um
stable baselines 3 installed in pytorch
obviously
let's go ahead and run through some of
the basics of gym and these environments
and and how things are working so we'll
import jim and then
m will be gym.make and in this case
we're going to make a lunar
lander
v2 as an aside i've been coding almost
entirely with copilot and it's so
painful writing things out completely
i've been super spoiled
so every time you have an environment
before you can actually step in that
environment you have to do an m dot
reset so we'll go ahead and call that
and then we can print um
sample action
and we will do m dot action space dot
sample so we're just going to see an
example of what is an example action for
this environment and then
we can also print
uh obs observation
space
shape
and we will say
uh f dot observation
space dot shape so painful typing things
out print
uh and we'll do a sample observation so
sample
observation
and we'll make this m dot observe
observation space dot
um
sample yeah
so
oh and that's a method
cool all right so once we have those
things let's go ahead and finally close
this off with an m dot close
and let's go ahead and run that
get rid of this
cool so sample action you can see here
is a zero if we run it again possibly
we'll get something else
right so just an example there so your
observation space shape is just a flat
eight values and as you can see these
are the eight values honestly i don't
even know what they are but it's just as
you get into reinforcement learning this
is what i mean by i think
the harder part of reinforcement
learning is no is less about the
algorithm yes you can tweak some of the
hyper parameters in your algorithm
but in general it's going to come down
to
your your environment your reward
mechanism and your observations so like
what you feed in to those algorithms
those algorithms especially by now are
pretty robust algorithms i mean
they still take a very long time to
train uh in that regard but if it's
going to learn it will learn and
changing those hyper parameters won't do
too much at least you can screw it up
but from the baseline values the default
values i have found you know i can eke
out maybe an extra five ten percent
performance possibly by tweaking hyper
parameters but for the most part the the
actual gains that you're going to make
are going to come from algorithm choice
but also like reward mechanism and yeah
your observation space so anyways keep
that in mind so um so yeah so these are
just some examples of kind of what we're
working with so in this case our
observation is just yes this flat vector
and then we have an action space of
certain values that we can pass
so
and this is hopefully
the
the fact that you know we don't even
need to really know what these values
are to kind of show you um how uh robust
i suppose stable baselines three really
is because you'll see as as we go to
train a model on this environment it's
not that stable baselines 3 just knows
the lunar lander environment it's that's
that's what's so nice about stable
baselines 3 is if you decide later you
want to change something about your
observation or your reward mechanism or
anything like that you just make the
change in your environment you don't
have to touch your algorithm at all
and that's what makes it
it just it makes it it really really
helps it saves so much time so let's go
ahead and see an example of our
environment in action so if we go ahead
and do four step in range
200
we'll do m dot render and then we will m
dot step and in this case we're just
going to pass a random action so m dot
action space dot sample
so we'll just do a random action here so
we'll go ahead and run that
and here we have our
agent so it just ran for 200 steps that
was actually a really good
really good example let's do another one
it's not the worst random usually it's
like flies around um not bad okay so
uh yeah so so we have that also that's
like really small let me uh okay that
looks better so hopefully we'll be able
to actually see what what's going on so
i'll kill that hopefully that'll go away
cool
okay so uh so that's just a random lunar
lander
now um what we one thing we can do is
every time you take a step you actually
are getting back an observation a reward
whether or not the environment is done
and any extra information uh that you
care about you might care about so let's
go ahead and print reward and then i'll
change this but i made it 5200 just so i
could
uh
modify the recording
so we'll run that and then we can kind
of see here so these are just our um
rewards essentially and since it
eventually crashed we got a negative 100
but here you can see the rewards are
whatever they are and again it's almost
irrelevant
as long as we can assume the
environment's been been made
reasonably well which we know the openai
environments have when you go to create
your own environment it's completely a
different story but we'll get there
so
so now what we want to do is
train an algorithm on
this um
this environment so
what are some of the things that we know
about lunar lander well the only thing
we really need to know to know which
algorithms we can work with
is is it discrete or continuous and in
some respects that can actually get even
more complicated especially with like
there's discrete and then there's
multi-discrete so what does that mean so
if you have discrete that would mean
what we have here which is just discrete
your actions is you have one action
choice per step to make whereas you
could have multi-discrete like so in the
case of like a robot for example you're
actually trying to
uh
get
servo positions for let's say in my
example with doing the the biddle robot
dog there's eight individual servos
all that need uh predictions to be made
so that's a multi-discrete uh problem
for example uh if you're using a
discrete algorithm anyways
so uh so to know what we can use we can
come back
so to know what we can use we can go to
essentially the home page here go to rl
algorithms and they have a lovely little
table it almost reminds me of
scikit-learn initially which which
algorithm to use it was like this like
walkway path thing
i have many memories of like revisiting
that over and over uh for various
projects but anyways we can see here
what things can we work with so in this
case so box you can think of box as uh
this is your continuous discrete is
like the classifications and then
multi-discrete whether or not that's
supported uh and then multi-binary um
essentially that would that's going to
be the same as multi-discrete it's just
binary
um so uh so yeah so now what we're going
to do is we can check out let's just do
the first one on the list because we're
just going to say okay we want to do
discrete cool which ones of the which
ones of these which of these algorithms
can support discrete and we can see
there's there's a huge list that we can
choose from so we'll just start with a2c
to start
so how do we do this so again imagine
that this is like it doesn't have to be
the lunar lander environment this could
be your own custom environment which
again we will get to soon um so you have
this environment and what you want to do
is test
one of these algorithms on your
environment so to do that uh it's it's
just so simple from stable baselines
three we're going to import and we will
first bring in a2c all caps
so from here what we want to decide is
essentially once you have your
environment we'll go ahead and
i'll reset there and then we'll come
down here and then all we want to do is
first define our model so we'll say our
model is equal to in this in this case
it's a2c
uh this is a
uh mlp policy so mlp
police
policy um
and
we pass em
and then verbose will set to one for and
we'll we'll cover like tensorboard later
and stuff but
um for now this is pretty much i think
i've changed a lot of algorithms and i'm
pretty sure i haven't touched this
obviously multi-layer perceptron uh i
don't even know what the other policies
are but obviously there are other ones
i think that's just so it doesn't have
to be fully connected i don't know maybe
maybe that in a distant video but so far
through my personal uses of stable
baselines three i have not i don't think
i've ever changed this line at all i
think i'm just editing what algorithm
we're using anyways
now to train model dot learn boom done
so here we specify how many total time
steps how did you know that that's what
i wanted already
interesting
i have to double check copilot uh total
time steps 10 000 we'll set for now
so this will train for 10 000 time steps
it should go very very quick
and then we will instead
do
[Music]
i kind of want to change this code for
200 steps or do we want to just let it
go
i'll just let it go we'll say
well the correct way you would normally
do this we'll just i'll just write it
out episodes we'll set to 10 and then
we're gonna say so for ep in
range episodes episodes
what do we want to do well rather than
fourth step in range we're just going to
say
um
first we'll start with obs equals m dot
reset so other than step this is the
reset method also returns an observation
but nothing else there's no reward
because you just reset the algorithm
there's no info or pass or anything like
that so it just will return an
observation
so we'll grab that observation we're
going to set done to be
false
and then we will just simply while not
done
we will do
this
um i'm no longer going to print the
reward i don't want to see it also
stable baselines 3 will give us a little
output of information so no need so i'll
go ahead and save that and
um i think we can display it in here i
think that'll be fine
um so let me make sure i did everything
somewhat decently i guess we'll find out
go ahead and run it
so first we'll start training we're
already a thousand in 1000 let's make
this a little bigger so we can actually
see it so this is the length of the
episode so how long is the agent
surviving sometimes that's a very useful
metric to know uh and then episode
reward bean this is just telling us what
is our typical
average reward per episode
at this time step
there's other information here like
frames per second iteration all this
other stuff sometimes this will be
important to you sometimes not so after
10 000 steps we can see this is our
agent and actually given what i showed
you before of the random agent this
doesn't look too far off of the random
agent but i assure you the random agent
is worse than what we initially saw
but as you can see it's just it's not
very good so so the next thing that we
could do is increase the time steps so
we can go for a hundred thousand steps
instead of just ten thousand steps
and if you're wondering about saving and
loading all that that is the subject of
the very next video but for now
let's train this for a hundred thousand
steps
okay moment of truth
here we go
honestly uh that's not looking
oh not very good uh at least the the
episode reward you know average episode
reward did come down
but but that's still not that great
that's that's not the best that i've
ever seen right so yeah coming up um
wow it actually interestingly
so in this case
episode mean and then we come down here
it almost it looks like it got even
worse
over time
so about i don't have the full history
here unfortunately we will get to
tensorboard logging uh soon the next
tutorial uh but for now as you can see
um it was decent at around 70-ish
thousand steps and then um eventually
just kind of went bad
so um this is
why in the very next tutorial is going
to be saving and loading models and
saving as you train models because
this sort of thing is not uncommon but
for just to show you now you've got a2c
which is a you know
not as robust algorithm
we also have ppo so literally to try an
entirely different reinforcement
learning algorithm you just import it
and then we change it right here
and that's it
now we use ppo so again we'll do the
exact same thing
i'll just go ahead and run this
and we'll run this again for 100 000
steps and we'll see what kind of
difference did we get so we ended here
at negative 48 but at some point we did
actually get a reward of like 50.
anyway i'll be back when this is done
okay so we have our result and in this
case uh again it's almost it's very hard
to compare these two algorithms because
they both look
uh
quite bad after only a hundred thousand
steps i mean it's it's better than
random but it is comical how my random
example worked
pretty well and then the training
examples did it um
in reality we are training these models
for far too few steps so we need to
train them longer but as you can see
even like when we did the first ten
thousand steps well when we decided okay
let's try a hundred thousand steps well
we had to retrain the model all over
again so what really we want to do is be
able to save load and then track
performance and all that so that's what
we're going to be doing in the next
tutorial in this case uh the only
standout difference uh one is it trained
um maybe 10 percent faster than the a2c
model did
and then also
it's staying a lot alive a lot longer on
average um but again like i said neither
of these models even remotely close to
their actual training time so to put
that in perspective you know generally
you're going to do millions of steps so
i don't you know 10 to like 100 million
steps
i can imagine there are some
environments where you might even do
more than that um but anyways uh yeah so
by this point hopefully you have a
pretty general understanding of stable
baselines three reinforcement learning
kind of what are the the main uh you
know terminology like observation and
actions and steps and all that kind of
stuff
and in the coming tutorials uh we'll
hopefully show you how to actually start
using this to train a model and kind of
track its progress over time and then
eventually how to apply this to a truly
a custom environment a custom problem
and
really get into the nuts and bolts of
what i think makes reinforcement
learning hard which is actually
engineering your own environment
entirely it has really nothing to do
with these algorithms if you're
interested in learning more about neural
networks and how they work then you
might want to check out neural networks
from scratch a book by myself and daniel
kukiewa inside of which you'll learn how
to code neurons activation functions how
to calculate loss to optimization and
back propagation and of course apply
everything that you've just learned to a
problem the book itself is in full color
for graphs and code syntax highlighting
everything's on high quality pages with
full font and a comfortable line spacing
to make reading easy finally every
concept including the math and coding is
broken down into the truly atomic parts
and then put back together step by step
to give a full understanding of neural
networks and how they work including all
the math behind them by the end of the
book you will have created your own
neural network framework from scratch
this is the book that i wish existed
when i was learning deep learning and
i'm extremely happy to be able to offer
it to you if this sounds interesting to
you then you can head over to
nnfs.io to learn more and buy yourself a
copy
so anyways that's all for now thanks for
watching and i will see you guys in
another video
you